so the club is called Berkeley XR and
the idea is to inspire other students to
create and to use this new platform to
design create and compose music and art
so every week we would show them
different kind of gear or different kind
of software's or different kind of games
and experiences that he can do in
virtual reality and hope that some of
them will find it so inspiring that they
would want to build something by
themselves and I help a lot of my
students build their project they come
to me with a prototype or an idea and I
just go with them through the stages of
how to build this and to make this into
reality or virtual reality boom what's
up everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don sake on we are at MIT the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology in
Cambridge in Massachusetts we are now
going to be talking about creativity and
music in the era of VR we have surely
spikes joining us on the show hello hi
how's it going thanks for coming on all
right I'm so excited to talk to you we
have so much to unpack about the subject
surely spikes yes is the CEO of virtue
studios president of Berklee College of
Music virtual reality club and on the
advisory board at monk's she's
passionate about immersive technologies
and spatial audio unleashing our full
creativity in the era of virtual reality
and you can find the links below to
virtuous studios to play mucks woo jure
and her Facebook page as well so yes
check out those links this is gonna be
such an epic convo breaking all this
down let's sure let's start things off
with one of our favorite questions we
love asking people we find ourselves as
stewards of Earth what is it current
take on the state of our world it seems
to me that the world is going to a place
of valuing personal identity and
discovering yourself with creativity and
coming with the full potential of what a
person can get on any kind of field
yeah that's Bob yeah that's what's up
yeah I'm wishing the full creative
potential
yeah and valuing the the self discovery
of people trying to
reach that potential for me yeah yeah
the process of finding out what we find
to be most meaningful and fulfilling in
our lives and then going after that as
long as we have to have these right
physiological needs met we have to have
the right basic the tools that are
available to us yeah but we always have
that but what we have right now I
believe is the idea of you can want more
from life and that's okay and no one's
gonna judge you for that you can be
successful and no one's gonna judge you
for that
quite the opposite they're gonna help
you become even more successful than you
would think you would be so it's an era
that of experimentation and trying to
find the inner self of each and every
one of us yes yes it's crazy
thinking about the amount of I believe
it's somewhere around 1,500 total
billionaires on the planet and how it's
just looking like the as the pie of the
economy of the planet it's gonna grow
it's gonna be closer to 3,000 and
entrepreneurs and artists and people who
want to make the world a better place
people who actually want to change
things to the better and to the greater
good Jamaica audible yes yes it's like
billions of people around the world
gaining access to democratize
technologies exactly at the edge it
exactly yeah it's amazing it's a great
journey yes yes yes and specifically um
I think the technologies that you're
going to be teaching us about in this
episode especially you're gonna unlock a
lot of potential also yes yes let's do
the journey so okay when you're when you
find yourself born in Israel and you've
got a you're gonna have to teach us
about kind of like the craziness like
I'm really interested in what this is
like it's so much different than you
know being born in the US that's true
it's kind of like a much smaller piece
of land and that's true crazier are very
small pieces you're part of the world
yes so teach us about that and how you
picked up your you're interested in
music and then got out to the Berklee
College of Music oh I I started playing
when I was four so I don't remember any
time of my life that I didn't do music
or doesn't hear sounds in my head or
didn't analyze whatever's on the radio
so it was always a part of my journey
and Israel is a very very small country
located right in the middle east between
a lot of Muslim countries so we're one
of a kind I think because it's a very
small country a lot of people finding
themselves through the entrepreneur
journey just because we don't have a lot
of resources and people like okay we
need to generate money out of our ideas
make sense kind of severe yeah not only
yeah also hardware and also a lot of
stuff cyber defense which is Israel is
very big on so I always grew up around
entrepreneurs and people who want to get
something more out of life and I had a
lot of people that told me that in
Israel you actually feel like you were
living because something might happen to
you there oh yeah so there are a lot of
dangers in Israel but but you learn to
appreciate life because of it and then
can you give us an idea of like the
density of the like of powerful notes of
like individuals and companies a
majority of them are in Tel Aviv is that
Tel Aviv Herzliya is a huge one on
startup companies a lot of like I think
that the top 50 companies in the world
have already opened a Center in Israel
you have a lot of incubators there are a
lot of headquarters are based in Israel
a lot of companies actually started in
Israel a lot of companies that you're
using on a daily basis like ways for
example USB thumb drives were invented
in Israel yes yes yeah in my cherry
tomatoes as well cherry tomatoes cherry
tomato really invention interesting yeah
that's something that you're welcome
yeah yeah yeah
was the the vehicle that made the of the
late the Lane Assist where they would
yeah yeah that company also mobile I'd
mobilize mobilize yeah yeah yes you have
a lot of friends who work there actually
yeah yeah see what's up yeah what's up
yeah shout out to the Israel
okay so then all the way to you know
having since four you've always noticed
sound always known as song I always
notice sound I always hear sounds I
always analyze songs in my head I always
try to understand better music I went to
the conservatory in Jerusalem I grew up
in Jerusalem and I went to the classical
Conservatory in Jerusalem and I did a
few classes also in the Huayra cap
Academy in Jerusalem and then I moved to
school we call Ramon well back then we
called it Ramon today we call it a been
school at Berkeley International and
that's work school where all my credits
got transferred to Berkeley and I
studied composition arrangement and
conducting because I realized that I
didn't want to just be a player that
just plays to other people or play other
people's pieces I want to be able to
create my own music yes so I studied
composition arrangement and conducting
for three years and after that I took
one year off to study and get the money
to get to Berkeley who's really
expensive as you know yes this is a very
expensive school it's a very expensive
school I am on few scholarships thank
God but it's still a very expensive
school so this is a top Berklee College
of Music is one of the top schools in
the world for me yes yes yes and we
ranked in top like five or sosam and
it's world leading and being the top one
of music education and music technology
and the first one to get a degree for
film scoring the first one to offer
classes and virtual reality and and
video games
so there are groundbreaking in a lot of
different fields film scoring classes VR
yeah yeah
yeah the first one to get I think I
think it was the first school to get
jazz as like as a degree I think first
school in America to get all jazz is a
degree instead of just classical music
or traditional music so it was always
breaking the ground
Berkeley's Berklee College of Music has
been a little bit uh I'm always trying
to I'm trying to you know get in there
and see what's going on and just a
little bit older than my country
honestly when Berklee I believe was
founded in 45 my interest
yeah Israel was founded it for you yeah
the fine being of countries countries
and stuff okay so okay so yeah the
cutting edge of music technology you're
out here now you're doing electronic
production and sound design correct and
you call this the biology of music oh
that's not how I see sound and
controlling sound yes teach us about
this so yeah I started actually studying
film scoring and I moved to a different
major which is electronic production and
sound design and I didn't even know what
I'm getting myself into honestly I
thought it was just gonna be trance
music or you know party music but not at
all so the way I see it electronic
production and sound design is the
biology of music which is understanding
the depth of sound and how does sound
move through the air how can I control
it how can I manipulate it what does it
mean to hear a sound why does it sound
different when you play a notes on a
violin or in a piano even though it's
the same note why does why doesn't it
sound the same if it's all just
frequency and amplitude it should sound
the same but it's not so it's really
getting into the depth of what sound
actually mean and understanding how to
design it and manipulate it any way you
want
yes yes it's like taking God control
over a sound it's actually biology it's
understanding how things are built why
does
why does it sound bad why do we like
something better than the other thing
why does some sounds are natural and
some sounds are not and how does it move
through the space yes yes the same note
on different instruments exactly that's
a good one
you also had all these other ones of
which note to play how long to play that
note so yeah what's wrong yeah we work
with MIDI controllers that allow us to
control which notes you're playing in
which specific time and we buy the VI
for those who don't know em I di me T
this is the protocol that we transfer
audio from and a lot of our students are
actually designing MIDI controllers and
different ways of how to manipulate and
control sound using buttons using breath
control using petals using virtual
reality controllers for example so you
could use a lot of different things to
control and manipulate music yeah
because the days of the mouse and
keyboard
those are like long we're way of Pat
we're way going past that now since we
just teach us about yeah how meaty how
you would actually be able to do cool
things so yeah so the way we see it at
least in electronic music is less like a
linear piece of music less like this is
the beginning and then this happened and
then this happened and more kind of like
puzzles or blocks if you create those
blocks independently and then you choose
however you want to build them in every
different form and you can play them in
Reverse or you can play them in the same
time and you kind of create yourself
those templates that later on you're
using for different materials so the
same song can sound differently this is
why we listen to DJs how they take
different audio pieces and combine them
together to one big piece yes yes so
then how does how do I make one of these
kind of like MA modules and then would
you go about designing that and then
and how do you plug that in with the
rest of them how can you make it go
backwards speed it up amplify it so we
use something that we call da WS which
are digital audio workstation those are
soft words that help us control record
control edit and do any kind of
manipulation that we want own sound I'm
using few different ones so usually for
a live performance you would use a
software called Ableton Live for
building patches and to actually
understand the signal flowing the sound
you could use max/msp which is a very
nice software that you can design your
own sounds in other than that there are
a lot of different tools like Cubase Pro
Tools logic each one is using his
workspace and then kind of create music
based on the workspace that he chose yea
the tools are so many now and they're
just so many they always come up with
new ones which is great I think yes I
hope that the time that we spend
learning tools can translate into
knowing how to use the next-gen tools
because you don't yeah well I don't want
skills to just definitely definitely the
way that we perceive music has evolved a
lot from the single channel to the
stereo that is true for the song yeah
yeah so when we started playing
instruments and starting performing as
humans we did it firstly in small
chambers usually in royalty families
when we call the chamber music like a
small set of instruments that we're
playing like a little a nice piece or a
minuet and then we moved into a bigger
Symphony halls and we kind of try to to
get the viewer to feel something bigger
and the way that the orchestra is
sitting the way that everything is is
designed and those Symphony halls is so
you can get the best sound possible and
they're sitting in there spreading
everywhere so you can get the entire
feeling of listening to a symphony
orchestra and from that we can go
forward in time into recording music and
for start we had only mono
if we recorded in mono and we listened
and monitor everything and then came
stereo who changed it everything that we
know about sound and suddenly oh my god
I have two channels and they can move
between them and I can like pan things
into a different mic into different
speakers and each ear can hear something
different and then we moved into getting
it on our smart phones and on our
computers and headphones became like so
much more advanced over the years and
you have now noise cancelling and you
have bone conducting headphones which
sits not on your ears but on your bone
conductor on your bone conducting their
code yeah and they send vibrations
directly into your brain without even
going through your ear so you can hear
two layers you can hear the real world
and can hear the virtual world or the
non-existing world in your ears in the
same time and it comes to today where I
think that our world is going towards M
sonic and spatial audio so in the past
what we used to have we didn't have a
definition for that but now we call it
headlock music which is music that is
just locked to your head that means if
you hear something in headphones if you
move your hand if you move your head the
sound is gonna stay the same doesn't
matter how you move you can walk you can
turn around and it's gonna sound the
same and we took that and we amplified
it today into ambisonics or spatial
sound so firstly you can hear the room
and it sounds way more bigger and depth
secondly when you turn your head the
music is gonna move based on where it
sits in the room so let's say I have a
drum kit right here and I hear it on my
headphones and when I move my head it's
gonna stay in the same place instead of
moving with my head just like we hear
music on just with our ears and the idea
is that we we're not only hearing left
and right we can also hear back you can
also hear front we can also hear up and
down yes we don't have that in
headphones yet we're starting to get
into that and understanding how to
record and to get sound that is
immersive into the world of virtual
reality the 360 sound ambisonics is so
cool because we're talking
you know what used to be we would go
movie theater we'd go to a surround
sound system at our house and it's so
cool when you can hear the person
walking from over here to over here but
then these are also have so much healing
potential meditative potential spiritual
potential I mean definitely for
everything experiences that we can
design inside of a Masonic chambers
mm-hmm I mean when VR let people feel
different places let people visit
different places let people feel
something that they've never felt before
actually enhance them with sound movie
theaters are already doing that using
the Dolby Atmos Studios so what they did
is they design kind of a 360 environment
with speakers everywhere and the sound
just travels between them and now the
composer it doesn't even have to know
about this you just have a little
joystick and he can choose whether he
wants the sound to go so he doesn't even
need to say now we want it on speaker
number 17 and now we want it on speaker
number five no it doesn't for him and
you can make automations and you can
actually make this sound rotate around
your head or move around the space which
i think is wonderful I just love the
simplicity because it is really
democratizing how easy it is to be like
you're just like what's a joystick now
and it's just thought and and it's just
like the simplicity for creativity and
this is so critical for for human
ingenuity I'm really looking forward to
that being unleashed more and I want you
to drop us into you being the president
at the VR Club that is true so last year
I started the club actually with my
friend Maxine Gautier
he came to me he we talked a little bit
about the club and then he said yeah I
need a co-president who would manage it
together with me so I started Berkeley
XR that's the official name of our club
and the idea is to inspire our mixed
reality right it stands for okay so XR
is an
a term for virtual reality augmented
reality and mixed reality so a lot of
people said that it's expended realities
or extended realities or extreme
realities and each time it happened one
company just coined that or decided that
that's their thing so now we just see XR
as an umbrella term for everything that
has to do with immersive technologies so
the club is called Berkeley XR and the
idea is to inspire other students to
create and to use this new platform to
design create and compose music and art
so every week we would show them
different kind of gear or different kind
of software's or different kind of games
and experiences that he can do in
virtual reality and hope that some of
them will find it so inspiring that they
would want to build something by
themselves and I help a lot of my
students build their project they come
to me with a prototype or an idea and I
just go with them through the stages of
how to build this and to make this into
reality or virtual reality yes yes so um
this is cool because you're doing what I
think if we could get to more labs and
communities right this is so critical
you show new gear and those can make new
experiences you show 360 video you show
record you've recorded potentially video
games tell stories in the VR of course
yes yeah total platform that allows you
to do whatever you want and this is an
exciting time because VR is so new that
whatever you do in this field you're the
first one to do that there are no rules
no one's gonna tell you all this is the
way to do things there are no ways or
protocols of how to do things you can
design whatever you want you can come up
with a new idea right now and if you're
probably gonna be the first one to think
about that which is I think is a very
exciting time for everyone for any kind
of field to go into virtual reality I've
seen designers go into virtual reality
I've seen architects I've seen
mathematicians physicists doctors who
use virtual reality
psychologists using this new platform to
either tell theirs
or you help their patients help their
clients whatever it is this medium can
take it you just need to put your hands
on it and not be scared of new
challenges I love how you said the
frontier in this field is that you know
with only maybe a couple million of
these of these extended realities
umbrella terms across these Hardware
devices across the world right now if
you have an idea for it
you are really potentially one of the
first ones to have that idea for it and
then to actually be able to execute it
you're gonna be seeing tens of millions
of people using these platforms soon
even hundreds of millions and then
you're gonna have a mass you're gonna
your whatever you built for it hopefully
will be part of a massive library that
will be used by so many people more than
that you could be the leader of that you
can determine this from now on this is
how we work you can actually change the
history of virtual reality right now
yeah imagine that any kind of field that
you're studying you're hearing about
those breakthrough people who just tried
something different tried to break the
rules and see what happens
virtual reality is so new that anyone
can have their place to do that and I've
seen so many amazing ideas we have a
student for example who is trying to
visual visualize mixes in virtual
reality like how does a compressor work
how does a reverb work how does all
those tools that we're using to create
audio how do they actually look in space
mm-hmm
I had another student who was working on
ecology they look in space I was so
interested right that is so interesting
I don't know I don't know we're gonna
have to check up without students so
he's still working on that project Josh
even just how the sound is being
propagated through the room we had
people yeah we had people that did 360
videos we have now the power station of
Berkeley in New York
we just acquired the power station it's
a big studio that used to be for
recording a lot of big artists like a
virgin was recorded there for example
and today Berkeley is using that for
recording music but also for 360 videos
nice yeah yeah yeah this is pushing the
edge even further yeah yeah how hard it
is to be the first one to do something
today how easy it is to be the first one
to do something in virtual reality
think about that scene yeah do you want
to really add another app to the App
Store or do you want to potentially go
and pioneer virtual or augmented reality
how hard it is to be the best jazz
player in the world how easy it is to be
the first player in virtual reality just
the first mmm it's kind of like Mars
yeah or it'd be the first one on on Mars
be the first one to close that's another
thing that some of my students created a
market or on Mars through virtual
reality so you can actually visit Mars
yeah there's so many that are working on
the planets yeah yeah it's so much fun
visiting celestial bodies yes so much
fun yeah the the the uses of this are so
endless and I really what kind of want
to hear what your thoughts are on this
you know we were gonna drop into the
next uses of this for you but what do
you think about the human mind
especially the child's mind like of
course learning from a textbook versus
learning from spatial intelligence with
an augmented or a virtual reality it's
almost as though I the brain is just
gonna be able to capture the knowledge
so much more effectively I think it
depends on what but a lot of things
virtual reality can actually help you
study be more focused for start we have
so many distractions today and everyone
keep talking about the distractions and
the phone and the Facebook and your
emails and everything in Viana you can
do that you only have a headset and
that's it now you're immersed for 10
minutes and you're gonna stay in those
10 minutes and you're not gonna check
your Facebook on the background because
you can't because right now you're
immersed into this new world a lot of
people have called Virg
to reality the perfect empathy machine
yeah because that is the first time that
you can literally walk in someone else's
shoes yeah you can feel what it feels to
be someone else to get out of your
comfort zone for just a second from your
own living room and to find a new story
so I think it's a great medium for
storytelling for sharing experiences
with each other and for creating just
new content everywhere and I think that
anyone can find something that he's
passionate about and just bring it to
the new world of virtual reality which
is how I got into virtual reality
honestly I just took my passions and I
said you know what this is what I like
let's let other people enjoy what I see
as fun or what I see is exciting
yeah you can't I can't get up I can't I
can't get over that when you can really
get behind the eyes of someone you can
really start gaining a sense of empathy
and right now the what we're doing is
we're doing oh I wonder what this
person's life was like the last 20 years
can i really get behind it and try and
understand it so now you can you know
you can go as deep as even people that
are being displaced around the world or
have really corrupt them it's a really
tough ways to meet the basic
physiological needs that way you can
potentially become more aware of that
and want to participate if initely yeah
yeah definitely I get together it's
interesting is like perfect empathy
machine yeah I definitely agree that it
could be a very good source for empathy
I also do believe that like I too I is
just so critical like passing you know
good like a minute just like looking at
someone else's life you need to be very
cautious with VR that's what I think a
lot of people will use it for bad things
you need to understand the risk that
you're taking when you're stepping into
someone else's shoes mmm that's how I
see it there was someone who created a
VR experience to show what it feels like
to live in a hostile environment of
domestic abuse yeah
and in this environment you're a woman
being verbally attacked by your husband
who is yelling at you and throwing
things at you and I've heard of people
who are crying and people who really it
broke them down to pieces and you need
to be very very careful the role that we
put ourselves through in VR is don't do
anything in VR that you would regret in
real life yeah yeah yeah anything that
you would regret in real life don't do
it in New York
why if I'm not gonna in a physical world
be like oh I you know I should really
know what it feels like to you know be
physically abused by someone else it's
like I don't I don't want to doing the
physical I don't wanna do the viral
world we need to just eradicate that or
are killing people or killing people
just get it yeah out of our physical
world and not have to put people behind
it in virtual spaces so they can better
empathize because we're changing
people's physiology when they go behind
the eyes like that yes it could really
tear apart people need to be very
careful with that yeah I'm glad that you
brought that up I think that's a really
important one yeah yeah and and but I'm
not okay on a more positive note we have
yeah virtual Studios I guess videos you
can find that Lanie before built in the
bio below you guys you guys won the the
reality virtually hackathon at MIT top
ten innovative ideas the top ten and
inviting ideas in 2017 and 2018 2018 I
won with a different group with a
different group yeah so that's still
huge you want twice in a row that's
thank you job good job
and so then you this is the development
of these immersive musical experiences
married music and VR so yeah teach us
about behind the conductance see like a
law that hackathon changed my life
honestly they even called me the year
afterwards to talk about my experience
in the hackathon and invite other people
so that was my first year in Boston I
was here for two months I could barely
even speak English coherently and I
decided you know what I need to know
people I need to find out people I need
to know the scene I need to know who is
against to and who do I need to talk to
so I signed up for a bunch of hackathons
and one of the
ended up being the virtually a reality
virtually hackathon and I entered there
and I didn't know anyone I didn't know
anything I didn't know anything about VR
back then and I sat next to a guy and
usually what I do is I just offer my
services as a musician and as a composer
and a sound designer and say yeah I can
do music I don't know anything about VR
but let's do music and there was a guy
sitting next to me and he he said
something boring about blockchain I
didn't even bother listening to him and
then he asked me what do you do and I
said well I'm a musician I do music they
said oh yeah maybe you can like design
and instrument and VR that like I don't
know when you move your hands it moves
and I said what you mean like a theremin
in VR and he said yeah just design a
theremin in VR and I said why theremin
if you can design an entire virtual
Orchestra that likes it's everywhere and
then you can be the conductor and then
you can control everything just like a
real conductor does on stage and you can
like cue them and stop them and
everything and he told me ahead he
should pitch and I looked to the other
side and that guy was sitting next to me
and there was another guy and I'm like
hey dude I'm pitching how's it going and
I pitched my idea I had he joined me and
after three days of work we'd created
the first in the world virtual reality
Symphony Orchestra that can be control
with actual hand gestures just like a
real conductor does on stage how I got
into VR
that's what's up yeah you're just you're
weak sometimes we need these we was
really a theme of people that sit with
us on the show is these these bits of
stimuli that come from mentors or from
family or from people around us in their
environments that they're just like do
so about that oh you mean like uh-oh and
the soup okay so tell us about you know
the hardware and how I can just go okay
violins and we're using the medium of
virtual reality and we're using the
immersive 360 space to design the entire
orchestra so you're standing right in
the middle
the conductor is standing and you have
your score and you have the entire
orchestra just around you where the
first violin sits right to your left and
the last double bass is sitting right to
the other side so you can actually it
takes away your entire space see you
physically need to move your head to see
everything which I love about VR I hate
when people just use it as a 2d space
for me VR use the 360 so we design an
entire Symphony Orchestra and we're
using a tool called leap motion to scan
the hands of the player and based on
simple gesture that conductors do we
were able to teach people how does it
feel to conduct on stage and honestly to
be honest with you the best sound is
from the conductor point of view if you
want to get the best point of view to
hear a symphony orchestra it's right
where the conductor's I love that yes
the entire like all the music just comes
right to your ears
oh what a cool yeah and then if it's
Amba sonic right there may be rows
whether you exactly so if the double
bass are sitting here the cellos are
here and the violins are right here if
you move your head they would actually
stay locked in their position not long
to your head and you can get the
experience of how it feels like to
conduct a full symphony orchestra this
is so the future of immersive
experiences it's like the ambisonics the
virtual reality the spatial engagement
process these are all such critical ways
to people to unleash creative potential
in its sense yeah I love it and you can
sign up in the link yeah yes well sign
to our website and we're gonna send you
some updates about your game
I love it virtual Studios everyone check
it out videos and then also on the
advisory board at Moss yeah that is
pretty new cool a MUX yeah so it's MUX
it's already on Steam so you can already
buy it it's a game that lets you does
sound in virtual space or you we're
using modular synthesis ideas so you
using tools like an oscillator or a
cut-off filter or lfos which is a low
frequency oscillators and you patch them
together to create your own patch that
can play sounds or you can trigger the
sounds by yourself and you can create an
entire show using just virtual reality
so I just got on the advisory board of
this team this is another really
interesting one and where you have some
images that you can see them back here
it's just like so cool how you can take
and move around different pieces of
music and in the 3d space actually
create your own instruments with your
own unique sound yes that's the fun part
about it yes yes we were talking a bit
about that also unlike them right now
the best we can do is really like voice
and like you can do a little bit with
like other but like to be able to really
go deep into creating your own
instrument to feel like you're inside
the track but you are a part of it it's
its surrounding your world
it's osoo so I'm literally I'm in them
like you're in the meadow you can just
build it through the space you can put
it everywhere you want and then you can
just step outside and build another one
next to it and then can then them to
each other so it's all around you it's
surrounding you with sound and I can
move my character through it and be able
to look correct and one of the things
that we're working on adding right now
since I got into the team is adding
spatial audio to it as well whoa so they
think that this is going to be a few
yeah yeah and then so I'm then the way
that the pieces are connected I can do
something like create a different rewire
the connection from the way that it's
moving every once in a while over here
and I can just imagine you can say let's
say you have like a constant sound of
and then you can take this and connect
the blood say to an LFO and then
suddenly it's uh
and it moves and then you can control
the the amount of time so to do that you
can control the the velocity of it you
can control anything you want and create
your own instruments and understanding
sound in a better way
yeah this this world around us feels
like it sometimes is being designed by
audio creators there's so many things in
our world that like when you pay
attention as close as you do when you're
four you know when you're really really
starting at a young age to start paying
attention how it all sounds around you
and you can dive in by like closing your
eyes it's not as fun as it sounds it's
not as fun I love it we're aware of all
this sounds like we don't have
background music it doesn't exist no we
have background we don't have background
music because when we hear music even if
you put it in the cocktail party we're
gonna hear it right here
we don't have background music it's not
a thing that like exists in our brain we
always hear everything that is happening
around us see but that's it I like that
a lot but I also hear that hear you on
how that can be you but when people ask
me what is your favorite kind of music
or what do you like to listen to and I
say nothing are you crazy to listen to
music on my free time yeah you don't
know what you music I listen to when I'm
at work now I want to I want to rest I
want to listen to silence yeah I want to
listen to silence when I'm resting I
want to listen to absolute silence
yeah what are those anechoic chambers
like you yeah yeah yeah you get locked
or just go into the studio yeah yeah
noise-canceling know what I haven't
listened to music on my own time that's
that's that's yeah that's that's like
yeah when you're like whatever field
you're in if you're doing that field
even like before you sleep when you wake
up in the morning it's like you're an
entrepreneur then right like what's that
how I did yeah you know what happens
when I listen to music I would listen to
a song and then I would say huh that's
kind of a catchy song that's nice huh
that's a cool song Ollie did this
okay and then they use this I would have
used it differently I would have like
design it like this and I would maybe
like add a file in here or maybe like
some horns over there and maybe it's
some drums oh I know I drama that I can
call you know what I can book the studio
for next week and then I can record this
and maybe then we can call this singer
to do the arrangement and then like we
can yeah yeah that could actually work
and that happens every three minutes
every time it song changes every time
SOG changes is haha yeah I mean while
I'm over here like all there's music I
didn't even notice that I just left like
Spotify on almost sleep and Spotify oh
yes yes that's very funny year analysis
yeah when you when you go really deep in
a field then everything is like you're
like yeah ologist you're like yeah wear
clothes and do everything skin yeah it's
all it all becomes in a sense yeah your
field that you're going deep in okay now
let's do what your yeah okay yeah so
teaching us this is an Israeli company
and this has a crazy haptic feedback
suit you feel sound it is so I'm working
on the content creation for this company
and they're called butcher and they've
created two things firstly they created
a haptic feedback strap that you can put
on you and then they created a bigger
one that is called the would your vest
which you wear on yourself and it can
take sounds and turn them into vibration
based on the frequency of the sound so
you can physically feel sound and not
just hear it yeah it enhances all the
experiences you have especially on
virtual reality which is mainly what I
use it for and we're working on creating
sounds and libraries for them that can
work with their suit so you can not only
hear sound but you can also perceive it
as actual vibration just like you would
hear it at a club so the biggest
difference between how you hear music in
a club or how you hear it in your own
headphones is exactly that it's the subs
and subs are notes that are so low that
our ears can't even hear them but you
can feel them as vibrations when you
hear it through headphones the
vibrations are not
there because the sound is not strong
enough so you get the feeling of being
in a club without it which is really a
revolutionary thing yet the feel as
though strapping you into a wooja
permanently is fun because you would be
like hey you could be like I don't want
to keep feeling the sound all the time
how do you yeah meanwhile I would be
like oh this is cool but then event and
there's so many applications for this I
was telling you a bit about David
Eagleman a neo sensory and yeah how
that's interesting for people that are
deaf that they can actually be able to
feel the vibration of words and learn
words it's like new senses or it's a
very interesting concept to be able to
use haptics to hack our senses we're
trying to use it also for physical
therapy for helping with physical
therapy we're using it for anxiety
attacks usually when people feel an
anxiety attack they need something to
hug them and to hold them that is a
great way to do it using the vest we're
working with blind people and trying to
get them get like a room scan and then
whenever they get close to one of the
walls it would start vibrate on just one
side so you wouldn't know that you're
getting closer to a wall and you're
about to hit it so we're trying to find
a lot of different applications for it
as well as introduce it to virtual
reality and music and virtual
experiences just to enhance them and to
get more of the feeling of it yeah yeah
and haptics are also nuts because it is
such a crucial part of our immersion
into virtual realities as soon as you
can be completely strapped and when you
you know step on the twig you actually
feel it snap on your foot I mean we're
talking like some crazy crazy well
haptics I think is the hardest one to
recreate in virtual reality because
haptics is everything you feel it could
be feeling like a bump on your shoulder
but it could also be the sense of of hot
and cold or the sense of fur versus
steel or it could be anything anything
that you can see anything that you can
touch need to have kind of a sensation
and I think it's one of the hardest
topics in virtual reality but the
Woodrow company it was designed by
musicians for musicians and it works on
waveforms so it actually detects audio
and I think that a lot of musiah
musicians would love to try and use that
and then you also went and told us a bit
about the way that lead this actually
leads us in this says this actually
really interesting leads us into the way
that DJs are now at venues and they have
ambisonics systems that they can use so
Dolby Atmos is already open I believe
three or four venues in the world for
spatial audio that means that the entire
venue is surrounded by speakers and the
DJ goes onstage and it can actually
create sounds that are moving through
the air and they said that you just feel
like you're inside the track just
immerse inside it while you're in a club
with your friends and suddenly a sound
just comes and round around your head
and just goes away I think it's a very
cool experience and I think that we're
gonna see more and more of them over the
years
the immersive experiences are going to
be taking a huge foothold in society
definitely definitely and I want to hear
some of your thoughts on the future of
all of these technologies kind of
coalescing where do you see at all so
firstly I'm seeing virtual reality
becoming more mainstream and more people
adopting it and I think that one of the
fields that haven't adopted it yet is
fashion and once fashion people with the
fashion degree would actually get their
hands on it and say I can do it better
we would actually get fashionable
glasses that we can all wear outside and
we're not gonna look as stupid as we
look now with VR
because a lot of people are telling me
I look dumb or I can't see anything with
it so I believe that this is gonna
happen sooner or later also though the
hardware hardware side of things it's
just like taking the compute off of the
glasses and putting the computing in the
cloud and then the 5g infrastructure and
me definitely think those 10 gigs a
second or something really we're getting
there we're already in the place where
our phones can run VR which is
incredible your phone your like pocket
computer can actually run virtual
reality simulations yes it's not the
best of course we have a lot of work to
do but we're getting there and the more
I see people complain about virtual
reality the more I just want to tell
them just give us a few more years I
promise you were working on that we're
getting there is just take some time but
a lot of people are complaining that for
example you can't move more than one
meter we're working on it just give us
like a year or two and we're gonna get
there or people are telling me yeah okay
I get it you can shoot things but what
else can you do and really we're working
on it you see me I'm working on few
projects at the same time and inspiring
others to create content for it so we
can create an ecosystem we're we all
profit from virtual reality and then I
think it's going to become way more
mainstream more people are gonna use
that more professions are gonna use it
not just for video games oh look there's
thousands for doctors there's thousands
for architects so we do using that
they're already using thousands Oh in
the Viacom the library oh my gosh look
here unless general they're using
virtual reality and augmented reality to
treat patients they're already embedding
into their systems for example doctors
who want to treat a patient but they
need to to keep clean hands but they
need to write something down instead of
actually taking a pen and paper just in
space just use augmented reality to
write something in space see you yeah
yeah architects why show someone a
blueprint if you can just let them walk
in the building you haven't even
yes just let them walk in it enjoy it so
I believe that more and more industries
are going to realize that this is the
future and it's already here and you
need to adapt to it yeah and then I want
to ask you a couple questions that we
typically ask on the way out all right
episode this is a be interesting to ask
you all right are we in a simulation are
we in a simulation are we I don't know a
lot of people have called me the glitch
in the simulation so maybe maybe not
I don't know does it matter you're
smiling you're having fun does it matter
if it's a simulation or it's real for me
it doesn't matter as long as I'm
enjoying the ride okay okay and how
about what is the most beautiful thing
in the world oh wow that's um so I see
beauty define I see beauty hmm I see
beauty as three elements that needs to
come together for me and I call them 3h
so the first one is heart that means
that you need to have your heart than
something and you need to actually truly
believe in it and love it
secondly is your head it needs to be
well thought and well processed and the
third thing is hands which means it
needs to be well crafted and well done
and those three combined together can
create actual beauty that's a good
synthesis oh thank you yeah yeah sure
thank you so so much thank you so much
it's so inviting we have sorry
the edge is being pushed you're pushing
the edge in the face you're unleashing
so much of the cool potential that we
have with creativity and music in the
era of VR I want everyone to take a look
at Shirley's links in the bio below
virtuous studios.com playbooks calm
Luger calm also her Facebook to go and
check that out
support support go and keep sharing this
type of content around the more people
are co-workers or friends or family
online communities let's get talking
about virtual reality be that first in
that crew to be able to create and wanna
be the first go there don't be afraid
that's right I'd be afraid of a
challenge it's gonna be worth it that's
right that's right
and support the organizations and the
entrepreneurs and the artists that you
believe in around the world
that's a support simulation our links
are below help us continue coming to
cool places like Cambridge and
conducting interviews and awesome people
like Shirley and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world we love you very much thank you
for tuning in I will see you soon please
good job
[Applause]